seriously we live in the age of the
reboot the Remake the sequel or the
prequel why can't they just create
something new welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular site tracker you
will know that every other week I'm
talking about something that's being
planned to be rebooted last week it was
The Last Starfighter before that it was
um space above and beyond
um even Stargate has been considered to
be rebooted and Firefly and every other
damn show ever made we've had lots of
reboots in the past sometimes they work
Battlestar Galactica sometimes they
don't
you could even really consider all the
current Star Trek to be a reboot even
though that would be a soft reboot a
reboot where on the whole they remember
that the other shows actually happened
the hard reboot is when you pretend the
old show didn't happen at all
but why does Hollywood insist on keep
making these damn shows well the cynic
inside me believes that it's quite
simple really they do it because they
know there's a ready-made audience
people will watch
actually getting a show and then getting
people to watch it is quite a difficult
thing
imagine Firefly
imagine they've actually advertised that
well and got people excited about the
show before it came out then people
might have actually watched it and then
it might have actually survived more
than 14 episodes
but they didn't because they got the
advertising woefully wrong
um FOX also then messed around with the
schedule and they did all sorts I
actually genuinely believe if Firefly
was made today and put straight onto a
streaming service it would have survived
because people would have watched it it
could have been a bit of a slow burn
maybe but all of the episodes for the
first series would have been dumped in
one go people would have watched it and
it would have been a massive hit but
because it was put on a network a
network that advertised it badly and
scheduled it badly nobody watched it and
it failed
and these shows nowadays cost a bloody
Fortune any new Stargate series even if
it's 10 or 12 episodes will probably
cost anything up to 150 million dollars
to produce now that is a massive
investment for anybody it's a really big
check to write and at a time when there
is a big squeeze on the entertainment
industry particularly our streaming
services that have traditionally spent a
lot of money on new shows a lot of TV
and executive producers and things have
got a little bit nervous so what do you
do when you're nervous you go with
something that you consider to be a bit
safer in this case a reboot a remake a
prequel or a sequel if you can make a
sequel or prequel of something
that people already love it's far more
likely even if you don't produce a
product that's particularly good to get
people to at least watch it at least
initially and then hopefully they will
fall in love with that project and
continue to watch it
but you get over the first hurdle
immediately the first hurdle getting
people to watch it in the first place
now I actually have no problem with
sequels I like the idea of continuing a
story the only time I ever have a
problem with a sequel is if when they
rush it so for example Die Hard biggest
hit of the Year massive surprise hit
nobody had any clue it was going to be
that bigger movie so they rushed a
sequel instead of doing a sequel that
was thought through and planned and with
a good story they did something really
quickly and it just failed another
problem with sequels is they're never
quite as good as the original and very
very few films are um T2 aliens you know
Godfather part two other than that most
sequels are weak compared to the
original though but it's because they're
compared to the original Predator 2 for
me actually is a pretty good film but if
you compare it to Predator it's a
Crocker [ __ ] I do have a problem with
prequels I hate prequels
I'm really worried about strange new
Worlds at the moment as a prequel
because as I've said in a previous video
the difference between a good show and a
great show you need to have a really
good bad guy the problem with a prequel
is you already know who the bad guys are
you already know what happens because
you've got the app series from the
future to comparing
for the Federation we know who the bad
guys are we know who the threats are
from that period because we've already
seen it so they can't give us a new bad
guy they can't give us a new threat
instead what they have to do is try to
rehash existing threats the gaun for
example in strange new worlds and try to
make them more interesting some have but
the result of that is you destroy Canon
so I'm not a big fan of prequels but
again the reason why prequels get made
and reason why they get created is
because of our desire to understand why
a TV show got to where it did so we like
to know how something happened why did
we get to this point if that the new
series started what is the background
what is the history we like to see that
we're going to see that in Game of
Thrones even though it's set way before
but I would argue again it's a bit of a
waste of time because we already know
what happens so I have absolutely no
problem with SQL I hate a prequel but
reboot and a remake
they very very rarely work Battlestar
Galactica worked basically because they
were 30 years between them so that kind
of worked sometimes projects need a
reboot or a remake because they get so
complicated it's the only way to do it
but I would argue in that case just
don't sometimes a rebooter remake is a
good thing because even though say a
movie had a really good idea and was
maybe a cult classic it was not made
very well the special effects weren't
good enough or something like that and
actually we could do a remake now and do
a much better job but even things like
that are kind of rare there are rumors
they're going to try to make a remake of
Flight of the Navigator now that is a
movie that does not need to be remade
the special effects actually because
they were simple and subtle still stand
up today and still look great there's no
reason to remake that movie another film
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory that
was again maybe I'm being cynical but it
was remade for the cha-ching for money
because things just wanted to there was
no reason to remake the original because
the original was beautiful on its own
so most of the time if a film is done
right in the first place you don't need
to do a remake or a reboot but they
willed it because of the name because
it's a film we recognize so a film we
will watch
and it's as simple as that they want
bombs in seats because getting somebody
to sit down and watch a new show to
become invested in a new series is
actually an incredibly difficult thing
to do so by doing a remake or a reboot
they cut out the middle map they cut out
that initial problem and that is why we
live in the age of the reboot and the
remake
so get into the comments guys tell me
what you think do you agree with me or
am I way off basic
um do you like a remake do you like a
reboot do you like a sequel or a prequel
am I wrong about prequels by the way I'd
love for you to tell me in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and if you enjoy the
content consider hitting the join button
and becoming a fully fledged side
tracker as always please stay safe I'll
see you next time
[Music]